[Applause]
hello everyone my name is Martina Selene
and that is Yanni and I'm gonna tell you
all about that in a moment but let me
first you say that it feels so great to
be here on this stage I'm just so happy
to finally be here and get to show you
all this game that we made this whole
thing called unravel I'm the creative
director at the cold wood we're under
the studio made up of 14 people from you
know in northern Sweden and I think that
games are really powerful things they
have the ability to grab you and move
you in a way that few other art forms
can and that gives us as game makers a
certain responsibility I think we should
try to do more than to just entertain an
arrival was created in that spirit it
was born out of the need to make
something more personal
something with a heart it's a puzzle
platformer where you play as a little
character made of yarn which unravels as
you move and the yarn it represents love
and the bonds that we make and it
unravels because that's what happens
when we were separated from what we love
in this game you are the red thread that
runs through someone's life trying to
tie all their missing pieces back
together now I made most of this design
while I was on a camping trip with my
family way out in the countryside I was
so full of ideas but I didn't have a lot
of tools to work with out there so I
figured I could just kind of like act
out the gameplay and that's how how your
knee came to be and I actually brought
him with me
hi know I created this little dog with
some old metal wire that I found in some
yarn that I managed to borrow and then I
just like I wonder around in the woods I
was putting your knee in different
situations and snapping pictures and
figuring out fun ways that you could use
your yarn and I wanted all game to feel
just like that - like it's an
exploration is a quest where you have to
be clever and creative to find the
proper path and the game is centered on
yarny this this little character was on
a big journey and accomplishing big
things despite being so small the
gameplay is all physics based you have
to find the way forward and overcome all
these obstacles that you'll come across
and those problems can have simple
solutions like using your yarn to swing
across a gap or sometimes things might
get more complex so when you look back
at that tangled and winding we belong
left behind you have to stop and wonder
how you ever got there it's kind of like
life I mean I certainly didn't see
myself standing here today back when I
was playing with yarny out in the woods
two summers ago but here I am and I am
really really glad that I finally get to
share this name with you all unravel
thank you
unravel means a lot too is a cold would
we we put our hearts into this and we
hope that when you play it you will feel
that so thank you and enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]